[Music]
let's talk a little bit about
experiences of ritualized surrender
right psychologists often tell us that
it is in the act of letting go that you
find out who you are the prospect of ego
death however the prospect of any kind
of ritualized surrender feels like dying
but only to those who resisted those who
eventually come to realize that there is
no such thing as death at least that
psychological dying into the moment is
but an illusion the last hurrah the last
resistance before you earlier yourself
into the abyss and realize that it's a
featherbed you know Terence Mckenna
talked about this he said this is the
secret this is what all the shamans the
professor's the wise men this is what
they understood this is the alchemical
goal this is how magic is done you early
herself into the abyss and you realize
that it's a feather better our society
today is constructed we know this in a
way where many people are afflicted with
the pathological amount of anxiety and
depression that's what Jamie wheel calls
21st century normal this relating
anxious state from an overactive ego
stemming from a misfiring default mode
network which is the autobiographical
mind which is essentially metastasized
into something that is a kind of
autoimmune disorder of the self and the
excessive rumination and
self-consciousness that characterizes
depression and anxiety both come from a
mind that has become too ordered too
rigid to hyper-vigilant it's like we're
all living with a perpetual micro pts
and what the research tells us and this
has informed so much of my creative life
with the research now tells us is that
in safe containers and with the proper
precautions deployed the experience of
ecstatic surrender the experience of eco
death what Jamie wheel calls the Bliss
[ __ ] crucifixion is actually where all
the healing is done right it is when you
die into the moment that you realize
that all your fears are unfounded you
come to see that everything you want is
on the other side of fear it's like that
David Fincher movies a game reveals to
us in that line that says quoting the
Bible John chapter 12 verse something
whereas once I was blind now I can it is
hard to put language to these instances
of ecstatic surrender right hurling
yourself into the abyss and realizing
that it's a featherbed arrives you at a
domain that exists outside of time the
self experiences this as a liberation
from the incessant inner chatter we are
free to be ourselves we become infinite
as what it feels like the transitory
enchanted moments in which we hold our
breaths
compelled into aesthetic contemplations
we neither understand nor perhaps even
desired face to face with something
could measure it to our capacity for a
wonder when experience afresh the hardly
bearable ecstasy of direct energy
exploding and our nerve endings we
recontextualize the self as a marvelous
conduit in a timeless hole from which
molecules and meanings flow from neurons
to nebula and we see the world in a
grain of sand and we see heaven in a
wild flower we hold infinity in the
palms of our hand we hold eternity in an
hour
[Music]
and then the moment will pass and all
contradictions are reconciled
man has surpassed the gods what do we
find
after these enchanted moments what do we
after these moments of OPA de dat
adjacency when we spill ever when we
overflow when I cracked open so that the
light gets in we find that people report
increased feelings of well-being in
their baseline reality increased
feelings of compassion increased
feelings of creativity increased
feelings of joy a sense of having
glimpsed noetic truth
a sense of having tapped into the
infinite a feeling of communion with the
cosmos an ontological awakening a
spiritual experience of forceful
reckoning with what is a mainlining of
space and times through the optic nerve
we become what we behold and we behold
the infinite
you do when I'm on a road a tragic sense
of life it turn in the eternity nothing
is real that is not eternal
so the question remains right we know
the way we know the path we know what we
must do to heal ourselves how might we
turn our passing illuminations into
abiding light how might we turn our self
systems from leaky buckets right
Hollanders full of holes
into chalices said Jamie we how might we
render ourselves old how might we render
ourselves wholly
this has become the central
preoccupation of my life
you
[Music]